[Musique]
ma grande famille pour mon frère et mon autre famille
J'attends j'étais à Kahramanmaraş
Le lieu principal du tremblement de terre était là dès 9 heures du matin
je suis là depuis 9h
Je n'arrive pas à dormir, nous voyageons, nous voyageons
Nous ne pouvons définitivement pas dormir
[Musique]
Les 6 dernières personnes sont parties
Il y a aussi des enfants de 17, 10 et 7 ans.
Il y a une femme de plus de 35, 40, 65 ans, ma tante.
Mais non, toujours pas joignable
[Musique]
Bien sûr que ça compte, bien sûr que ça n'a pas d'importance
Est-il possible
Nous subissons également de nombreux tremblements de terre chaque jour.
puisque c'est arrivé deux jours deux trois personnes cinq
on ne veut plus le mettre en terre
Nous ne pouvons pas pleurer comme si nous n'avions plus aucun sentiment
même
[Musique]